bonsoir Jimmy
Jimmy vous avez aimé j'ai mis certains
produits vous allez une douzaine ou
parler donc vous allez parler
spectateurs j'imite quelles sont ses
produits on va parler du pain au
chocolat le pain au chocolat qu'est-ce
qui se passe avec la chocolatine le pain
au chocolat alors celui-là c'est celui
acheté en supermarché celui qui pose
problème je le mets au micro-ondes après
il est tout chaud comme ça le chocolat
et tout et je mange comme ça on dirait
que je mange des couilles au chocolat
j'adore ça il est vraiment j'adore ça
alors dis-nous le problème de ce pain au
chocolat qu'on achète en supermarché on
va acheter en grande quantité donc on va
acheter 8 et on va éclater le paquet
très rapidement or si vous voulez manger
un paon chocolat de temps en temps allez
la boulangerie prenez un vrai pain au
chocolat le problème de ça c'est que
vous avez 23 g de sucre dans un seul
morceau de chocolat alors 23 grammes
qu'est-ce que ça ne succès 4 morceaux de
sucre comme ça quatre morceaux sucre par
pain au chocolat très souvent vous allez
en manger deux parfois trois
c'est du sucre dont on n'a pas besoin
sucre qui va être transformé ensuite du
coup en Grèce c'est quoi ça donc c'est
de la graisse tout simplement c'est de
la graisse l'illustration de graisse 150
g de graisse donc 250 g ça ça devient ça
ça va devenir ça puisque le sucre
consommé en excès sous forme de graisse
on va prendre du poids et ce poids il va
se répartir sur l'ensemble de nos
organes et j'aimerais juste dire aux
gens que quand on prend un kilo et bien
un kilo de graisse c'est ça donc à
l'inverse lorsqu'on perd 1 kg et bien
c'est énorme et moi j'aimerais dire aux
gens qui perdent un kilo que disent mais
non mais ça marche pas si vous perdez un
vrai kilo de graisse et pas du muscle
pas de l'eau et bien c'est une bonne
chose vous allez perdre tout ça c'est
lourd c'est du poids c'est là c'est
vraiment quelque chose de significatif
or sur la balance on se dit c'est pas
terrible donc soyez patients dans la
perte de poids en essayant d'éliminer
des petites choses du quotidien
je suis con comme une savate je me suis
dit parfois je mange quand je mange un
couscous
le lendemain je prends 2 kg le couscous
il paye pas 2 kg donc pourquoi j'ai pris
2 kg alors il faut pas se peser la
veille pour le lendemain souvent parce
que l'excès de la veille va se
répercuter sur le poids du lendemain il
est raisonnable de se peser par exemple
une fois par mois au même moment du
cycle par mois plus au-delà en fait par
jour
je vous pèse après en fonction de ce que
vous buvez de l'activité physique ou de
ce que vous allez manger le poids va
fluctuer de 1 ou 2 kg et vous allez un
peu psychoter donc une fois par mois
c'est largement suffisant au-delà on va
rentrer dans un contrôle du poids qui a
présenté des troubles du comportement
alimentaire donc encore une fois souvent
les gens disent mais avec toi Jimmy on
peut rien manger vous pouvez manger du
sucre la seule chose c'est que la
consommation excessive de sucre va vous
favoriser la prise de poids et puis
d'autres maladies ok alors oui des
questions oui alors j'ai mis pas de tout
ça parce que j'aimerais que tu me fasses
un petit point sur tous ces produits
l'inflation et 2 secondes ça les cordons
bleus industriels j'adore alors ça mon
fils adore ça alors franchement
il y a du genre il y a du jambon
là-dedans alors il y a plein de choses
normalement le cordon bleu c'est du
poulet du jambon de dinde du fromage et
de la panure quelque chose très simple
[Applaudissements]
le problème de ça c'est que ça c'est un
produit ultra transformé industriel et
c'est encore plus vrai je suis désolé de
le dire pour la viande halal qui est
souvent de mauvaise qualité pour les
cordons bleus la viande halala les
industriels qui vendent du produit halal
comme le cacher par exemple quoi bien
finalement ils mettent beaucoup de
cochonneries dedans ils mettent de la
cochonnerie
non
pas de l'oral
lorsque vous allez au supermarché
tourner l'étiquette et regarder que dans
un cordon bleu vous allez voir une
trentaine d'ingrédients notamment des
nitrites on parle régulièrement des
nitrites qui sont des conservateurs
parce que normalement la viande
dedans en quelques jours elle va pourrir
or le cordon bleu on peut le garder très
longtemps c'est nitrite c'est nitrate et
bien favorise le cancer on sait que le
cancer colorectal est favorisé par les
nitrites dedans dans ces cordons bleus
vous avez du mono phosphate du
diphosphate et du trifosphate ce sont
des animaux dit et trifosphate qui
favorise les maladies cardiovasculaires
donc en fait le cordon bleu industriel
tel qu'on a pu le manger il est néfaste
pour votre santé dernier élément il est
peut-être c'est plus important on parle
de contexte d'inflation sur le plan
alimentaire c'est nul c'est nul vous
avez environ 10 g de protéines 10 à 12 g
dans un cordon bleu pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée c'est ce que il y a dans un
skieur en fait pour
en fait c'est pas vrai également c'est
un type de yaourt d'accord
et qui est riche en protéines 10 g de
protéines très peu de sucre ça coûte un
peu cher on le reconnaître du coup il y
a une alternative c'est le petit suisse
tout simple nature qu'on peut donner aux
enfants ça ça pose pas de problème il y
a très peu de sucre un tout petit peu de
matière grasse mais on peut rentrer
ne jamais
lui donnera jamais
c'est vrai que le petit suisse c'est
incroyable regarde le petit ouais c'est
mon truc préféré alors je vais le manger
je vous jure que je vais le manger
regardez bien le problème ne jette pas
de la nourriture
et voilà bravo bravo
ça faisait longtemps ça faisait
longtemps il rechute
[Applaudissements]